[Music]
how many of you are there not enough
eight people abducted from or near STAR
Labs here's the potential perfect
parademons okay
the demons must have caught the scent of
the mother box they carried people away
to find out what they know so the eight
mister be alive
nine the head of STAR Labs was taken as
well you made it so then there must be a
nest nearby
I plotted all the sightings of
Metropolis Gotham no pattern I can see
the lines on the map don't converge on
land Beasley back to practice tonight
live between the two cities Gotham
Harbor
these are air vents they all need down
to the tunnel to Metropolis project that
was abandoned to this Friday night
[Music]
do you really think that oh wow they
just they really just vanished huh oh
that's rude
[Music]
getting suffered but I'll take it from
here do I know you
[Music]
perimeters games
what are we under right now
Gotham Harbor
I know you have abilities I just don't
know what they are my special skills
include viola a web design fluent in
sign language gorilla sign language
silica based quartz and fabric brazen
resistant heat resistant yeah I do
competitive ice dancing what they use on
the space shuttle to prevent it from
burning up on re-entry I do very
competitive ice dancing whoever you're
looking for
[Music]
he's a Batman
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team people with special abilities you
see I believe enemies are coming stop
right there
I'm in you are yeah I need friends
hey everybody a whole bunch of Justice
League just drop so let's break it down
there were a bunch of Easter eggs for
classic stuff especially that Danny
Elfman Easter Egg you guys probably
heard at the beginning of that there's
gonna be a whole bunch of comic book
stuff coming up between Avengers
infinity war and all the Justice League
stuff that'll be dropping soon so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's a ticket giveaway that I'll
explain at the end of the video to the
scenes give you a pretty good idea for
the character interactions obviously
Steppenwolf vs. the Justice League is
really badass that just gives you a
sense for his power levels like there's
no way they're gonna be able to stop him
before Superman comes back so it really
just gives us our first up-close
high-definition look at him and it
probably just took him that long to
finish the CG on him which is probably
why you haven't seen him in trailers
before and I think they wanted to avoid
some of the doomsday problems they had
with Batman V Superman trailers but I
think the better analogy for that is
revealing Superman like Superman is
supposed to be the big surprise of the
film Steppenwolf we saw during that
deleted scene in Batman vs Superman
so we already kind of knew what he was
gonna look like but it's cool to see
cyborg take over Batman's crawler and
reconfigure it based on his technology
the mother box that's fused with him
evolves over time based on his needs so
there's some new situation that demands
new weaponry or new defensive
capabilities the suit will just manifest
that as he needs it but it's also cool
to hear Batman explain the Flash's suit
and just starting with the beginning and
going through the Easter eggs as we go
along I cut this way down there was some
more footage but it was footage that
we've already seen before so I didn't
want to include it just because it felt
redundant but we start with the classic
Danny Elfman Batman theme from the 89
movie they reused that for the animated
series most people probably remember
from the animated series but raise your
hand if you're old enough to have seen
that Batman 89 film in the theater that
was so badass when it dropped but it is
fun
to go back and watch it now just to see
how styles have changed since then
[Music]
but we heard them talking about mother
boxes the parademons have their scent
they're trying to track down the one
that's in cyborg so they're capturing
humans that they think can lead them to
it they say they just captured cyborgs
father we saw that during a previous
trailer this is what he looks like and
this is another trailer where we
actually see what the mother box itself
looks like cyborgs carrying it around
probably one of the coolest Easter eggs
from that flash clip though is where he
says he's fluent in guerrilla sign
language that's just a gorilla grodd
easter egg so it implies that we'll see
a version of gorilla grodd when we get
to the flash movie now truth be told
they wrote the script for justice league
before they had a clear plan for what
the flash movie was going to be but
there been so many reshoots that i think
that if they didn't want a tee up
gorilla grodd in the future movie they
would have taken that line of dialogue
out I think I've talked about the Rick
and Morty episode playing in the
background in a different video but it's
just funny to see that pop up in the DC
Universe so Rick and Morty is a show
that exists in the DC Universe you can
see Dan Harmon and Justin roiland
cheering in the background when they're
talking about the fight with Steppenwolf
and they say that it's in the tunnels to
the abandoned Metropolis project in 1929
the only real big thing that happened in
comics in 1929 is that Buck Rogers
debuted Batman Superman
they didn't debut till the late 30s so
there wasn't any DC Comics stuff
happening in 1929 but let me know in the
comments what other Easter eggs are you
hoping to find they probably cut a giant
portion of the film out like they
probably filmed what could have been a
four-hour movie but it's closer to like
two hours so there's probably a [ __ ] ton
of Easter eggs that didn't make the
final cut that they'll just include when
they get to the DVD they doing a good
job like with the extended cut of Batman
V Superman you get a couple of extra big
Watchmen Easter eggs just for moments
that weren't super critical to the
theatrical cut but that's one of the
most fun things now it's like when they
do shoot an epically long film and just
pack it full of really cool stuff that
never ends up making it to the screen
the completionist in you just wants to
know what that was even if it wasn't
super important for the story probably
the only other really cool new thing
about this is you get a better look for
how Aquaman's tried it works and what he
looks like when he's swimming through
water like we've seen him underwater but
you haven't seen any extend
scenes with him yet so the way Jason
Momoa describes it and he's mostly
talking about the Aquaman movie because
most of that will be underwater is that
people in the water environment feels a
lot like outer space so think about the
way people feel in an outer space movie
that'll be kind of like the environment
of Atlantis albeit with you know sort of
that blue tinge it'll be interesting to
see how they accomplish that CG and if
it looks very close to Justice League or
if they decide to tweak that a little
bit because usually even within the
course of a year
CG gets really good and if they find
they spend a lot of time working on
something and they think of something
better along the way they'll incorporate
that into the next film there might be a
little bit more footage but just let me
know what kind of videos you want me to
do if we have any specific requests but
there'll be a whole bunch of infinity
war Star Wars the last Jedi and
obviously Justice League and Aquaman
stuff they haven't said anything
official but they finished shooting the
Aquaman movie a while ago so I think
they have enough footage to cut a
trailer or a teaser to release sometime
before the end of the year so we'll
probably get a really good look at that
but there's a new round of that Justice
League ticket giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber or leave
a comment on the video congratulations
to the winner from the last video ren
goku please private message me so I can
get your contact details you can click
here for all my thor ragnarok Easter
eggs and post credits videos and you can
click here to learn all about that
Superman prequel show that's debuting
next year thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight